I find your lack of faith disturbing
don't hurt me Lord Vader relax this is
not a weapon of the dark side it's the
aala water bottle the coolest way to
stay hydrated the aala water bottle has
a patented flip-flip that lets you sit
chug or pour with ease it also has a
lock button to prevent spills and leaks
plus it's made of stainless steel and
vacuum insulated so it keeps your drinks
cold for up to 24 hours perfect for
those hot Tatooine days and best of all
it comes in a variety of designs
including this awesome Darth Vader Buton
most impressive so what are you waiting
for get you a Walla water bottle by
clicking the link in my bio and join the
Empire today